-Welcome back to the show,
everybody.
You know, not a lot of things
are certain in this crazy world.
We scurry through life
lickety-split
from one fleeting experience to
another.
Nothing seems sacred anymore.
Nothing seems permanent.
And that's why this week at "The
Tonight Show" we're saluting
the one thing we know is still
permanent, the permanent,
a.k.a. the permanent wave,
a.k.a. the perm.
That's right. It's the return of
"Tonight Show Perm Week!"
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ It's Perm Week ♪
♪ On the Fallon show ♪
♪ It's Perm Week ♪
♪ Oh, my God ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is "Tonight Show
Perm Week."
It's a very special week where
every day we pick someone
from our audience and stylishly
perm their hair.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Since it is a Valentine's Day,
tonight we are perming not one,
but two people, a couple.
Yes. The lucky perm recipients
are Tamara Doherty
and Kami Cotter.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Tamara is from Staten Island.
Kami is from Colorado.
And they're very excited about
their new hairdos.
It's been a big day for them.
Take a look.
-Hi. I'm Tamara Doherty.
-Hi. I'm Kami Cotter.
-And today we're getting perms.
Hearing about perms, I did have
to go on to Google and to check
if it was straightening your
hair or curling your hair.
-I'm hoping it's not
like too poofy.
This really wasn't my idea.
I kind of just tagged along.
-I am kind of going after Dolly,
the queen of the perms.
I would love a little bit of
Drew Barrymore perm
in there as well.
-I'd rather be at a spa day
today than getting a perm,
but it will still be
a Valentine's Day to remember.
-You can't plan a perm.
It's just gotta kind of happen.
So I'm ready to see
who I look like.
-I can't wait to see what Tamara
and Kami are going to look like.
Now, they've been sequestered
since they got permed.
So they haven't really seen
themselves yet.
And they also haven't seen
each other.
This entire process has been
cloaked in secrecy.
[ Laughter ]
Audience, are you ready to see
the brand-new,
freshly permed Tamara and Kami?
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Drumroll ]
Here they are before.
And here they are now.
Tamara and Kami, come on out!
-♪ Oh, my God ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my God.
-Wow. What do you think?
-It is amazing.
-What do you think?
-I said I'd love if she could
look like Julia Louis-Dreyfus.
And I think we nailed it.
-Yes.
You did -- Wow. I love it.
Do you like the look?
-I don't know yet, Jimmy.
-Oh, that's right,
you don't know yet.
Have you ever done anything like
this to your hair?
-No.
-What do you think?
Audience, this is pretty good.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Are you ready?
Happy Valentine's Day,
by the way.
Now for the most important
reveal of all,
Tamara, Kami, are you ready
to see yourselves?
-Yeah.
-Alright. Three, two, one.
Let's reveal.
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, Lord.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I love it.
I think you look great.
I think you look fantastic!
You guys look good.
-The curly girls.
-Look at the curly girls.
Come on. Do you guys -- Do you
like the new look?
-Yeah, I love the new look.
-You're keeping it?
-We're keeping it.
-At least keep it for
the next couple days.
-Yeah, until next
Valentine's Day.
-Until next Valentine's Day.
I love it.
Our thanks to the Mark and Ryan
Salon for these wonderful perms.
Happy Perm Week, everyone!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes!
Stick around, we'll be right
back with more "Tonight Show."
I love it! You look fantastic.
-♪ It's Perm Week ♪
♪ On the Fallon show ♪
♪ It's Perm Week ♪